you can't give away
what you don't have now it sounds
ridiculous
okay but it's more than
what meets the ear as you hear this you
can't give away what you don't have
people who are not good at giving away
love
can't give away love because they don't
have it to give away
if i want to give you a dozen oranges
i can't give you those dozen oranges
unless i go out
and pick up 12 oranges someplace
otherwise all it is is just empty
rhetoric
and the same thing is true of virtually
everything in your life
you can't give away love for others
if you don't have love in here to give
away
if what you have in here is contempt if
what you have in here is anger
if what you have in here is fear then
these are the things you're going to be
giving away
in your life and i've often thought
and i really believe very strongly that
there's a law
sort of a law in the universe i call it
the law of attraction
and the law of attraction is one that
works like this
you get back from the universe from the
world
what it is that you put out there in the
world
and if you're putting out there into the
world
that i am not worthy
of attracting something beautiful into
my life
that the universe will respond back to
you with exactly that message
and there are people who come to me and
who came to me for years when i had
uh my own counseling practice and so on
and they would say to me
um i just keep attracting the same kind
of
people the same kind of events the same
kind of uh
losers into my life why is that why do i
keep doing it i keep
attracting uh an absence of uh
of abundance i just can't seem to
attract abundance into my life i'm
always behind the
eight ball i'm never getting ahead and i
suggested them i said did
it ever occur to you that that's the
very kind of message you're sending out
to the world and out to the universe
that the ocean of abundance is there
and you can go to that ocean of
abundance
and you can take a mack truck and you
can
fill it up 20 times a day
and take it out of there and guess what
it doesn't impact at all the ocean of
abundance
it doesn't even go down a zillionth of
an inch it's unlimited
or you can go to the same ocean of
abundance
with a eye dropper and you can just take
this much out once a month and say
that's all that seems to be available
for me
and the interesting thing for me is that
when people
go to this ocean of abundance this uh
unlimited world all that i have is thine
it says in the holy books all that i
have is thine
it's all there for you but if you
believe inside
that it's limited that you can only get
so much
that other people are gonna get it
before you do then you'll find yourself
creating that very same thing and the
even more interesting part about this
you can't give away what you don't have
principle
is that if your message to the universe
is gimme gimme gimme which is a lot of
people's message to the universe i want
this from you i want that from you
please give me this i have to have that
that's what their prayer is like that's
what their message is
you know and they say i want this from
the universe give me give me give me
the universe's response back to that
kind of an
uh mentality is exactly the same the
universe will say right back to you over
and over again
give me give me give me
and you'll find yourself never ever
arriving
but always being in a state of striving
always feeling as if you're being
neglected never feeling as if you have
enough always feeling as if you're being
shortchanged
because you're constantly under the
pressure to give
to get back what the universe is
demanding from you
and the interesting thing about all of
this the the irony of this
is that if you shift that and you say
to the universe to the world
how may i serve how may i serve
the universe's response back to you is
how may i serve you
how may i serve you and it's very
intriguing
when you take your energy and your
attention off
of what you are demanding from the world
and instead saying what can i give to
the world
and it's really the the basis behind
that very famous line of the
uh president john kennedy's inaugural
address
ask not what your country can ask what
you can do
for your country and the irony of that
is and i've learned that in my own life
that when i stopped thinking about what
was in it for wayne dyer and how much
could i get and i began to shift
and say how can i help you how can i
give to you
what can i do for you and people who
write to me
i send them something when when i
encounter
somebody that needs help of some kind
i'm very often just giving that to them
and then i find
that it just keeps coming back into my
life and once i
shifted that energy off of what
can i have into what can i give
it seemed to me that the universe
responded back with the very same
message
what can i give to you and the most
incredible and wonderful and beautiful
abundance has flowed into my life in
every way that i can
possibly think of you can't give away
what you don't have there are no
justified
resentments and this is a very difficult
principle for many people to get
but one that i believe very strongly in
i was in a group one time
of uh drug addicts and
alcoholics and
i was one of the people that was a
sponsor
and leading this group and the sign on
the wall
said there are no justified resentments
in this group
[Music]
and what i said to that group that
that night was no matter what anybody
says to you here
no matter what kind of uh anger comes
directed towards you no matter how much
hate you may encounter showing up in
your life
there are no justified
resentments meaning that if you
carry around resentment inside of you
about anything or about anyone and i'm
talking about
the person that you lent money to and
hasn't paid you back
i'm talking about the person in your
life that you
feel was abusive in your life i'm
talking about the person who walked out
on you
and left you for somebody else i'm
talking about
all of the things that you have
justified in your heart
and in your life that you have the right
to be
resentful about and i'm suggesting to
you that
those resentments will always end up
harming you and creating in you a sense
of despair i've often said that
you no one ever dies from a snake bite
the snake bite will never kill you you
cannot be unbitten
once you're bitten you're bitten but
it's the venom
that continues to pour through your
system
after the bite that will end up
destroying you have a mind that is open
to everything
[Music]
and attached to nothing
one of the central principles of my life
is that no one
knows enough to be a pessimist
about anything and that each and every
one of us
when we close our mind to what is
possible for us or what
is possible for humanity closes off
the genius that resides
and lives in each and every one of us
having an open mind doesn't necessarily
mean
finding fault with all of the things
that you've been taught by others
it means opening yourself up to
the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible
so having a mind that is open to
everything
and attached to nothing really means
finding within ourselves the ability to
get rid of
a trait that i find so common in
contemporary
in the contemporary world do you know
that most people that i meet
spend their lives looking
for occasions to be offended
they actually are up out there hoping
that they can find
some reason to be offended and there's
no shortage of reasons they're out there
everywhere
the way this person dressed what the
west person said they turn on their tv
they hear the news they're offended by
this
someone didn't uh someone used language
that they didn't like
someone doesn't share the same customs
at you and people all day long in fact
if you keep track tomorrow you will find
probably 100 reasons that you can go
around being offended
but a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing
is a mind that says i'm never looking
for anything to be offended by
and that whatever anybody else out there
has to say my response to that is
that's an interesting point of view i've
never considered that before
the next principle i call don't die with
your music still in you
[Music]
and who better to quote than thoreau
right here in concord
when he talked about some of us hear
a different drummer and we must march to
the music that we hear
but all of you everybody watching
everybody here in this
beautiful parish all of you have some
music playing
and all of you have a heroic mission
there's no accidents in this universe we
all show up here
with a purpose there's an intelligence
that is a part of everything and
everyone and all of us are connected to
it
and too many of us
are afraid to listen to that music
and march to it you out there
i know you have a book you wanted to
ride i know there's a composition you
wanted to compose i know there's a song
you want to sing someplace
maybe you want to raise horses out in
montana or maybe you want to open up an
ice cream shop on cape cod
who knows what it may be maybe you just
want to travel and see the world
maybe you want to go into a relationship
with someone but you've been afraid to
but your heart says it's the right thing
to do
all of us feel something and in leo
tolstoy's famous novel the death of ivan
ilitch
he asks this question that would be
terrifying to me
he says as he has his accountant from
moscow lying on his deathbed
contemplating the horror of this
question
what if my whole life has been wrong
[Music]
i've known what my music is
it's playing right now
as i stand here in front of you with
these cameras and in this place
and as i sit down and write my books and
tell the world what i know
are my truths i feel always
completely on purpose and fulfilled and
no time will i ever come to the end of
my life and say what if my whole life
has been wrong
whoever you are whatever that music is
however distant it may sound
however strange however weird others may
interpret it to be
don't get to the end of your life and
know that you're going to leave
and not have it played yet don't die
with your music still in you
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days click the link right
below me and if you want my oprah
winfrey affirmations video
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe
i'll see you there